this is the number line we have zero in
the middle positive integers on the
right and negative integers on the left
when we move towards the right on a
number line the numbers keep increasing
and as we move towards the left the
numbers keep decreasing consider any
random number say 2 now choose any
number 2 it's right safe 5 5 is greater
than 2 now choose another number say for
even 4 is greater than 2 if we choose a
number to the left of to say 1 we can
see that 1 is less than 2 suppose we
choose minus 3 minus 3 is also less than
2 here's a very basic thing to remember
right means larger and left means
smaller and this helps us understand a
simple concept every positive integer is
greater than any negative integer it's
because all positive integers are to the
right of any and every negative integer